[Applause]
[Music]
Seline Dion the Superstar with a
showstopping
voice we celebrate the hit maker with
perfect
pitch what you never knew about seline's
humble start I'm the baby of uh 14 kids
only romance I never kissed another man
in my life and career that gave
[Music]
us we revisit seline's history making
moments your Royal Highness Princess
Diana and take a closer look at the
disease that is threatening her comeback
and I have hope this is ET Vault
unlocked Seline Deon I cannot ask for
anything better than that and it so why
not mother sister and the voice of a
generation celebrating the music
Powerhouse that is Seline Deion welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight we're
unlocking all our favorite Seline
moments from the ET vault as we learn
more about the rear medical condition
that is sideline Seline from the stage
indefinitely nice to meet you that
squeeze down let's not be shy you smell
great
so cracking jokes and smiling walking
and speaking without struggle Selen
stunned hockey players at their game in
Las Vegas in October it was the icon's
first public outing since March of 2020
10 months after she revealed the
uncurable condition that derailed her
career the very rare neurological
disorder called the stiff person
syndrome with labored speech Seline
explained severe muscle spasms forced
her to cancel all future performances
seline's sister Linda has reportedly
been caring for her ever since at the
singer Las Vegas home with older sister
claudet giving this Grim update we can't
find any medicine that works and there's
little doctors or the family can do to
alleviate her pain I'm getting treatment
from my doctors taking
medication but I'm still experiencing
some spasm and it's taking a lot longer
for me to recover the symptoms are not
that well-managed common medications are
valium or clopin which can help the
muscle
relax unfortunately these spasms affect
every aspect of my daily life and this
is really me oh yes it is Seline
appeared frail in her big screen acting
debut playing herself in love again she
shot the film in 2020 and wrote five new
songs for the romcom so courage don't
you dare
filing in one of our last interviews
with Seline in 2019 she was excited
about her new chapter and and courage
World Tour the woman that I am the
mother that I am it represents the whole
new life for me I'm
doing everything that I can to
recuperate and I have hope but through
it all Seline remains one of the
bestselling artists of all
time to tell you the truth I didn't
expect to hear my songs on the radio and
to be on the chart it's a dream come
true 11 number one hit singles 27 Studio
albums five Grammys more than 250
million records when you're happy in
life and you do what you love you don't
I don't do Show Business to win Awards I
do show business because I love to sing
et's been with the Superstar for all
five Decades of her prolific career
performing for fans including royalty
and
[Music]
president
I had the privilege for singing for the
Prince Charles and Princess Diana they
send you letters before and say don't
talk to them if you don't they don't
talk to you and it makes you really
nervous because you're afraid here we
are here we go and the world watched
just Seline sang at the 1996 Olympics
opening
ceremony lots of magic lots of lot of
pressure and in the full stadium and you
know the world is watching seline's
estimated net worth 800 million thanks
to 15 world tours and two
record-breaking Vegas residencies the
stage is my home it's the place that I
feel the most comfortable if I can build
a house on the stage I would do
[Music]
it we knew Seline was destined for
stardom in our very first ET interview
it was 1990 and at the start of what
ended up being her decade of domination
I'm the baby of uh 14 kids we all sing
this at age 22 this song off her debut
English language album became a top 10
hit in the US hitting the French
Canadian against the American divas of
the day there's one Madonna and there's
one Whitney Houston and there's one
Mariah caree I just want to be as I
[Music]
am
ET was on the set of seline's music
video for another top 10 hit on her
follow-up self-titled album which also
gave us this iconic ballad
beaut the 1992 track with peo Bryson
from Disney's Beauty and the Beast
soundtrack won best song at the Oscars
where both nervously performed in front
of the biggest stars
[Music]
around one of my idol Barbara Sten but
the song is not over I have to find my
my breath somewhere and continue the
song the awards kept coming the
following year the track helped Seline
win her first Grammy 20 years later I'm
still singing that song on stage what a
night for you huh it's unbelievable even
after winning her second and third
Grammys in 1997 Seline reminded us of
her humble beginnings as her dreams came
true when I was a baby I was watching
the tevision set and I wanted to be
here Seline also had this full circle
moment in the 90s getting to work with
her
Idol the biggest thrill that I've had in
Show
Business the decade was also a major
Money Maker for Seline whose 15 concert
tours have grossed over1
[Music]
billion in 1994 ET went behind the
scenes as the singer warmed up for her
first world tour from hitting the stage
in La this is what I go through every
[Music]
night to signing autographs in a
Montreal diner near the Forum where her
mom was in the
[Applause]
crowd four years later on the let's talk
about love tour she channeled the bgs
Seline secret to dazzling the crowd at
the end of the Show everybody's pretty
tired of being seated and like this so
why don't we just dance lots of people
so I cannot ask for anything better than
that and it so why not but selene's
success in the 9s wouldn't be complete
without
this it's truly an epic in every sense
of the word it just sweeps you out of
the theater with this with this
incredible feeling Titanic was bigger
than life it's like I can't wait to sing
it because I know that's what they want
to hear and when I
[Music]
hear and then I come and I'm like they
scam I'm like yes
yes ET was with Seline on the set of the
music video in
1997 would you say this is the biggest
Hollywood Premiere you've been to yet uh
definitely I just
met so
real Titanic took home an historic 11
Academy Awards in 1998 and ET spoke with
Seline right before she performed her
signature ballad on the Oscar stage the
reason for all the bodyguards well
Seline was wearing a $2.2 million Heart
of the Ocean necklace inspired by the
film feels very heavy but it feels very
I'm honored I'm wearing the
[Music]
Titanic later that night My Heart Will
Go On became seline's second Oscar
winning hit but check out this Titanic
secret seline's first impression of the
song wasn't good James Horner started to
play the song and and I'm looking at
your and I'm I'm going like
this I didn't want to sing the song I go
there I only sang it once the actual
recording of the album is the demo and
they build the orchestra around it thank
God they didn't listen to me the ship is
going to suck us down more than 20 years
after Titanic's release Selene
reimagined the movie's Mystique on The
Late Late Show with James Cordon in Las
Vegas
whose idea was that to recreate the
iconic Titanic pose their ideas I mean
James for sure in his
[Music]
coup Selene is undeniably the modern-day
queen of Vegas with two residencies
spanning over 16 years the 55-year-old
made history earning more than any other
artist ever we're talking over a
reported $680 million The Show Must go
on Seline reportedly performed nearly
12200 shows selling over 45 million
tickets in 2003 ET was with the singer
who is rocking a new cut for opening
night I fly it's always in the way
wardrobe changes a lot I'm a mommy and I
want quality time at home I don't want
to spend two hours doing my hair life in
Sin City me Seline didn't have to tour
giving her and her husband Renee a
chance to raise a family I live 30
minutes away from where the Coliseum
from where I work I go home every night
it's giving me an opportunity to have a
stability it also gave her an
opportunity to team up with fellow
Caesars Palace resident Elton John who's
the bigger Diva you or Elton together
we're not
[Music]
beatable she can sing anything she sing
the best ballad in the world she can
sing classical stuff and she can sing
soul and she can sing Rock and
Roll by
myself anymore
the show is going to be difficult to to
end the curtain dropped on her first
residency a new day in 2007 3 years
later Seline returned to the stage
earning a reported half a million
dollars a show she became the most
profitable Vegas accents Elvis Presley
fans got a behind the scenes look at the
singer's life and loves in owns Seline
three boys and a new
show I
am with love
Arm
I love fashion I love clothing this is
John gallano for
Dior do we know any girls in the world
who don't really like to be jeweled or
dressed up I never met one wow oh my God
give us a Spen Seline this looks like
the kind of outfit that means you're
going to party till 5 in the morning
maybe 6 in 2019 Seline went showgirl
Chic at the Met Gala and here here's the
truth this Diva has always loved to play
dress up I don't drink I don't smoke I
don't do drugs I sh in 1995 ET was there
as she browsed the designer stores on
the French Riviera her biggest Obsession
how many shoes do you think you own
3,000 5,000 I don't know I've heard
10,000 maybe I didn't want to say it two
decades later ET returned to France with
Seline that's where she revealed this
behind the scenes secret you do your own
makeup oh yes I do when I'm on stage or
an interview or I like to do it myself
and surprise another hidden talent I
definitely would love to do some acting
that's for sure I have different
characters inside of me she made guest
appearances on shows like the nanny
Touched by an Angel and all my children
et was on set with Seline and Susan
Luchi in 2007 it was wonderful we could
be best
friends
okay well now we know each other do we
know each other well yeah we know each
[Music]
other that was from my interview
backstage with Seline and Renee at the
World Music Awards all the way back in
2004 yeah to quote one of seline's songs
The Power of their love was real
unconventional and Unapologetic the duo
truly lived up to their wedding vows in
sickness and in health you were my
streng when I
Renee is with me all the
time I will never find love like Renee
again I have been still the luckiest
woman in the
world seline's beloved husband of 21
years Renee angelil passed away in 2016
after bravely battling three bouts of
cancer and ET was there as their
sweeping Love Story
unfolded heart
I went at his office and I sang in front
of him and I was 12 years old I was not
in love with him when I met him because
I didn't even know what love was Renee
started as seline's manager in 1980
despite Seline and Rene's 26- year age
difference they eventually fell madly in
love I got married to him the 17th of
December and I think I have a great life
that Montreal wedding well it was over
the top from the Gown to that headpiece
it was everything Seline dreamed of I
wanted to have my prince of charm
waiting for me Renee supported Seline
throughout her career been in 1999 it
was her turn to be by his side as he was
diagnosed with throat cancer I cannot
live in fear every day and say is he
going to die tomorrow the couple renewed
their vows in 2000 when Renee was deemed
cancer-free however in 2013 the cancer
returned we don't know about
tomorrow Renee passed away January 14th
2016 and received a national funeral
service at Montreal's notredam Basilica
the same church where they wed Seline
made her entrance holding hands with
their then 5-year-old twins Nelson and
Eddie 14-year-old Renee Charles was
linked arm in-arm with seline's Mother
TZ in one of the most poignant moments
he took to the pull pit and spoke from
the heart you're a tough act to follow
but with your help everything is going
to be
fine say
goodbye it's wonderful to know that he's
not suffering anymore I'm so thankful
that the way that he passed he called me
before my last performance he said I
want you to have a good show tonight I
love you I said I love you too I'll see
you later bye honey bye and I never
spoke to him again but I got three boys
and he lives through them even before
Rene's death Seline put Family First
often bringing her kids to work with her
and 2002 ET was with the singer on the
set of a commercial co-star in ree
Charles you have a little co-star with
you in the car this 22 months old it is
a great way to to to kind of keep him
near you right you bet in 2010 the Twins
were born Selene returned to work in
Vegas 5 months later what's been the
hardest thing for you when both of them
want to be held they're like 22 lbs each
now Eddie has a very very strong
personality Nelson is very gentle
Charming
they both have obviously their unique
personalities my oldest son RC he's into
music a lot and he's into sports he's
great in school yep seline's a
full-blown hockey mom she's been spotted
in the stands at RC's games the now
22-year-old released his first EP in
2021 RC is into Eminem and he's very
much into rap music my twins they play
piano by themselves I don't know what
they're going to do but the music is in
them for sure when are you going to
start singing I don't know about that I
don't think I have the voice for it but
he did have the guts for this at the
2016 Billboard Music Awards RC surprised
his mom with the icon award it was her
first live performance 4 months after
her husband's
[Music]
death it was Rene's favorite song I
turned around and I saw my son and for
him to come on stage I knew it was very
hard for him having the the privilege of
being a mom um it's my best reward these
are my three magnificent and children
thank you so
much are you okay are you
okay that was just a taste of what it
was like whenever we were with Selene
Dion she couldn't help but sing she's a
good time she like emanates Joy from
within now we leave you with more of our
favorite Seline serenades including one
of my did you try to sing with Seline
you tried to sing good night
everybody stay alive like a
[Music]
what a day what a day what a day what a
beautiful day honey you got to
move
like no I'm sorry it's really hard for
me not to sing I'm a single I'm single
I'm a single I feel like singing Because
You
Love